in this capsule we will see this
what is a genetic algorithm then a
genetic algorithm as we fly thanks
to an algorithm that makes it very
similar to the bing search algorithm
either local or stochastic so we have
here a description quite high level 2
what is another group
genetic
firstly in a genetic group one
will have a bit like in the bing
search a set of known that we are going
maintain as and when
searches this set has finally sent
refer to this together by committing the
population that will evolve as
measuring the execution of the algorithm
now in a genetic group
the successor of successor names
that will replace the nodes in our
generation population to water are going to
to be generated by combining father so
it's a bit like two
parents was breeding could has generated
a new node in the generation
next a level also be
represented by a good one makes a
string that is based on a
some alphabet it can be a fab and
binary or with multiple letters
so that actually corresponds a little to
code of analogy with genetics
is that it fits genetic code
from the north in question and the function
objectives that we try to optimize in
local search
in fact in the context of a goal
genetics on the fly called fitness
works or in finland or french
the adaptation function and there are three
very important aspects in the galleys
genetics that must be defined for
define an algorithm developed a
genetic otherness that's the part
commented selection what we select
two parents to annoy revival does not
commented on what we are doing
of these two words and finally
commented on what is being applied a mutation
on a child so obviously the
genetic hayot are inspired from
natural evolution process
in fact the motivation is also that
given that people are suffering
and made the result the process of
pollution such as we know thanks
to the work of researchers like darwin
- Mendel week so why not
use a lawsuit
model and implement this process
on a machine to generate a
behavior a human intelligence
an artificial intelligence in this
koh seah is a disadvantage of doing that
on a computer is that in this case
rather than having a generation that
takes 25 years we actually have
generations that can span out
a shorter amount of time so we
will not need millions of years
to get several generate
generations so maybe we can
hope to converge a lot more
quickly the green an intelligence that
natural evolution has allowed gold
so we will represent our space of
solution by a population
this population offers it corresponds
all of our every nova facts
correspond to the equivalent of a
chromosome so a chromosome it's going to be
a string of characters or
characters so match who encodes
essentially information about
our genes are only used a
set of characters a vocabulary
for an alphabet so goes for our
binary characters you will get a
binary string like that
then in a population to generate
children with simple procedures
crossover of two per year followed
a mutation applied to the child
generate and all this process there is going to have
a random aspect actually it's going to be at
the place in the parents section
then in the application or not of the
mutation and the children who are going to be
preserved will then be able to
reproduce according to their
adaptation
that's how it will be selected
to become parents in turn
to generate the next generation
so in fact the fitness function or
of adapting your correspondents our
function mdn we are trying to optimize
so here is absolute to the general code sure
that I am the vast majority of
genetic algorithms
so we start with a population that
is going to be a set of not generating
randomly that is to say that
whole healthy bodies our
population are going to be chromosomes
randomly generated so strings
characters eventually generated
randomly afterwards of one's must
specify a number of iterations so that
is going to be the number of generations that is going
be generated by the algorithm is to
each iteration initializes a
new population to the whole city
and when we're going to do that we're going
fill that population up by adding
1 to 1 2 1 until a child a new
element of the new generation for
do that we choose a first
Hate chromosomes that will be chosen
with a probability that is going to have to
grow that needs to increase depending
of fitness adaptation of the name in
question
to that we will choose a second parent
bonus
so it's a different chromosome that
loving the people we subtracted
the first hate chromosome that was
then choose from that we will make a
cross between seniors as a bonus that goes
give us the new born n canvas
the child with some probability
which typically will be relatively
little we will apply a mutation on
a star give me us
of alters 1 modified from chromosome one
star and this is your vote is
added to the population and so this
process there we repeat it until
we have filled our population
until having known in the new
population and finally to racing
assigns the population to the new
population and continue the iterations
like that so we generated a new
generation and then we continue until
we reached number iteration
of iterations and finally we're going
return to the very end
the node n among the last population
which is the value the function
adaptation the objective function the
higher so here's an example of
crossover that could be applied in
the context of the problem of a queen a
way of doing a cross it would be
to take back both of our parents so this
would be our own our first
parents n this is it would be our
second parent n prime the way of a
side so in the form of chromosomes this
state there it's a bit like the decree
before we know we are going for each
column indicated that the number of the
row where is the queen on this
column there and to make the crossing
by the way, what are we going to do?
randomly choose a separation a
two-part separation view table
so columns and then we'll take
in this case if we take the part to
right of a hate and we will merge it
with the left side of a premium hate
so in fact we choose seven years this
first under that of the hate chromosome
so we're going to hold with on the right of the
the left part of the chromosome ndp nothing
and that gives us a new chromosome
which is added to the new population
so this is an example of application
crossing that could be used
to try to solve the problem of
showcases now that we've seen how
crossing two parents commented what we
could in the case of the problem of
showcases
select his two parents there from
random way
when if we will define our function
of adaptation as being the name of
reindeer that does not attack so before
we had a functions function
goal which was the number of reindeer
who of reindeer father who are attacking
it was because in this case if we
was trying to minimize that number so
if we want to maximize ben we can
use as adaptation function the
number of reindeer that do not attack
so the minimum is zero then the
maximum is the number of bettors
finally know 28 in the code of 8.5
and a choice for the selection of the first
chromosomes it would be to use a
probability that is proportional to the
adaptation function
so we have an example here we have we had
a population with 4 as chromosomes
and there for each one we would take the number
the value of the function the adaptation
so the number of fathers who does not attack
not in this configuration there so I
will not do the derivation but you can
check that when 6 24 23 20 and 11
for the caps three men who at the top
and we finally normalize its
functions the adaptation the its values ​​of
adaptation functions to get some
probabilities to get so from
percentages that are 100 for that and
that's going to give us actually the
probability of selecting the first
chromosomes so we got 2 31% of
choose the first 29 the 2nd 26 the
third and 14 for the fourth so
we see that more than one chromosome
is a good solution to our
more problem to enjoy the 10
selected to generate a child in
the next generation is high and
so we see a process itie or for
the first child
in fact sorry the first parent who has
generated the first child
we chose this one here that come
still enjoy quite high 29%
to then select from yourself the
second by chance it was the first
element of our original population in
above that we chose a point or
divide the chromosomes and there in this
case also for this variant the hour this
who is a variant who who is
reasonable to use we will generate in
makes two children by doing an exchange
between the left part of a chromosome
parents with the party to the right of
the other so this is generating this child there
here to generate the second child
we make the selection of the other two
parties are the conquests a whole
so that's the selection part of
cross of parents followed by crossing and
I'm pointed out that in fact we
could have chosen several more
selection process
so there was where there is
a lot of freedom in the design of a
algorithm is genetic
the important thing is that the
probability of a chromosome there be
chosen increases according to its
adaptation function so in others
words the policy is chosen for
generate a child must go up
as the function
finally 2 how bad they are
corresponds a good solution to our
optimization problem and I would add
also the mutation part in this case
so what we could do is
simply with some probability
randomly choose one of the
elements of our chain
and then change its value randomly
also so we have the example here at pau
a mutation
but maybe at a priority I know
not me
25% we had a chance to have a
mutation here we would not have had here
would have had a more dense mutation
surety will not randomly choose one of
elements of the chromosome
then we changed it to the canvas so in
this case we went from 5 to 1
still there for the mutation yet another
times there are several possible choices
then from one application to another the
choice which is appropriate your charges and
then when we design genetic we
must think a little about quesques
what would be good
imitations the for our problem at
questions I want to finish with an example
who threads result of a student project
University of Sherbrooke
gabriel girard marc side elections and
symonds renault who actually have
developed a genetic algorithm for
an example an optimization we want
move forward
super mario as far as possible in
one of the super mario tables in this
case also the state end that will correspond
to the list of actions that mario does to
every moment of his life actually in the
chart so in fact the actions that
corresponds to each possible button of
the joystick and the adaptation function
it would be a function that will increase in
function of the distance traveled by
mario if he performs the actions in the
chromosome m
so for more details I invite you
to see the report they generated
following their project and here we have a
example of a
actually part of the table chart and in
did so much higher than so what
wants to do is find the list of
actions that will allow super bo to
to go as far as possible in the
chart then ideally to finish and
finally function fdn the way they
have defined in their projects
encourage and super mario to finish the
as soon as possible legally
so here we see an example of
the execution of the first generation
of war or genetic so as one
can see here since initialize
randomly it's not going big
thing
mario before his sentence but here it is
second generation writing but that's
in fact after several generations we
sees that mario advance more and more he
there is a little hesitation but we see that
it is a solution that is already not bad
by the way and that super mario
so my wheel will be much further in
done in the table after several
other generations we come to a
even better solution or the bari ace
to the advances a little more decided
without hesitation and will not be unhappy
Mario car managed to finish the
array is ultimately the generation
final the final solution returned by
the algorithm actually matches mario
that goes very, very quickly without any
hesitation until the end of the stable
then finally we see here a test of
their algorithms in a table we have
added an exaggerated fingernail of kompa and so
we see that there is still some
hesitation but still we have you
got a solution or mario succeeded to
get out and then get killed
speak as loudly